[Megatron] I tried to recruit her,
but there was still too much
Alpha Trion polluting her circuits,
just like you.
[Prime yells]
[echoing clatter]
[Prime] Huh?
Do you hear that?
Voices… on the other side of this wall.
-[banging]
-[Prime] Over here!
Can anyone hear me?
[groans] Those aren't voices, you idiot.
It's the environmental systems rebooting.
[pained groaning]
[Prime] I do not know what atrocities
you have committed to get here,
but the only way you will leave
is with my help.
It is time to set aside our disagreements
and work together.
No.
I would rather die in here
than be carried out by you.
I will not let you die.
[labored laughing]
You are so weak.
The single best thing
that could happen for you
and your idealistic crusade
is for me to die.
All you have to do
is not help,
and you can't even manage that.
Hmm. You should have killed me back there.
You could have learned the location
of the Allspark from any Autobot,
or even Teletraan-1.
Instead, you let me live.
Why?
Because you need me.
Ha!
[Prime]
Without me and my "idealistic crusade,"
you would never have amassed
the power you now wield.
I gave you exactly what you needed:
a villain for your Decepticons
to rally against.
But you still need me,
perhaps now more than ever.
So, here is my proposal.
I will help you out of this,
then you and I will retrieve the Allspark
and bring it home together.
After that, we go our separate ways.
This will be painful.
-[girder squeaks]
-[Megatron pained groaning]
[guttural pained groaning]
[yells in agony]